alors ça va être long ah ouais
franchement messieurs franchement adieu
j'admire ta carrière parce que réaliser
200 mais téléspectateurs avec vous fort
final tout le monde en rêve même moi je
pense que ta présentation à la star ac
sera gravé dans nos mémoires
d'ailleurs il ya eu une saison on attend
toujours la deuxième
tu vas tu sais chanter tu sais danser
musclé m je souhaite je souhaite que je
souhaite que ta carrière tu as aussi
musclé que tes bras moi il m'a défoncé
la gueule pendant 15 secondes c'est la
journée des mouvements c'est un
compliment comité spectateurs on se
reverra il va décoller parce que tu as
une nouvelle mais tu vas ou alors vous
savez que j'aime beaucoup
ouais alors que c'est que vous avez un
fond très bon ma carrière ma carrière
est derrière écouter les voeux leicher
sea shepherd j'ai caché que vous sachiez
qu'il a un fond très bon sens veut pas
de savoir rené qui parle de mes succès
il ya pléthore je vais tellement
producteurs notamment producteur en beau
documentaire n'est pas s'arrêter là bas
c'est bon on va pas faire va passer deux
heures sur ta gueule
[Rires]